thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
series get smarter by solving problems
at brilliant org slash Simon Clark lots
of people follow this YouTube channel
because of the vlogs I made during my
PhD in atmospheric physics at the
University of Exeter
unfortunately however I had to graduate
at some point and that necessarily meant
the end of my videos showing what doing
a PhD was like however there are lots of
people out there doing interesting PhD
projects and so in this video series I'm
spending a few days with a new
researcher each episode showing you what
their life is like learning a bit about
them and learning about the topic of
their thesis this episode I'm spending
some time with Zoey glass her research
at LSE in London writing her PhD thesis
on YouTube somehow she has turned
watching YouTube videos and writing
about it into a PhD project so to find
out how studying my job is her research
I met her with her at her home what
about this project interested youth in
it I've been very into YouTube since
2007 2006 7 I was fully part of that you
know when I was a teenager I like found
these people who did videos and it was
like the vlog brothers and
fiveawesomegirls and stuff like that and
those were the people like Mika kitty or
Tessa violet now I was very into
watching them when I was a teenager and
then I did vlogging for a bit in like
2008 and then I got embarrassed and I
stopped but ever since then I've been
like very passionate about what what it
is and the fact that you have like
community building and you can
communicate with people in any part of
the world and that that was really
exciting to me and then since then I've
seen a commercialism of the space occur
and I think that that kind of bothered
me and obviously since then it's become
like a huge industry and I and I think
it's fine now because I realize I see it
I've reframed it as a career so it's
like of course people are making money
that's there's no problem with people
making money yeah but I think there's
something about that transition really
fascinated me because it made no mistake
making youtube videos is a serious
career for tens of thousands of people
now in some youth demographics it's the
most desirable career making
entertainment for some 2 billion monthly
users on YouTube just like most careers
some very few lucky people are able to
make a lot
money from their YouTube channels while
most just about managed to make ends
meet I've been a full-time content
creator for two years now so I have a
natural interest in Zoe's research on
this subject but I was curious about how
she ended up studying this how does one
become a user well my undergrad was
anthropology I studied that so us in
London and they didn't have any
expertise in like internet cultural
media anthropology but I just knew that
I wanted to talk about online culture
and YouTube so I just did it and my and
that undergraduate dissertation was like
a very new topic kind of study of the
nerdfighter community in London in 2013
I wrote that and then I went away and
worked in television for a couple years
and then I did my masters of Goldsmith's
in digital media which was in the media
department and finally there were people
who actually were interested in talking
about media which is like I love
anthropology but anthropology is quite
slow to catch up with sort of digital
rights techniques so to be able to do a
PhD about it and get paid to basically
what you like meet my favorite youtubers
like that's really cool Zoe's research
takes the form of an ethnography which
means understanding the lived
experiences of her subjects youtubers by
immersing herself in those experiences
walking a thousand miles in their shoes
kind of thing this involves spending
time with them in person conducting
interviews and being part of their
ecosystem online so there's an auto
ethnographic component making her own
videos which somewhat gratifyingly she
said she found those difficult and
frustrating told you is hard however
another key component is attending
events out in the real world about
online video about its community and
about its industry and as luck would
have it a big one was right on her
doorstep this year one of the big events
and the online video
VidCon VidCon London is this weekend
zoey is here talking to youtubers and
getting more data collection in for her
thesis so I'm here talking to her if
you've never been to a VidCon it's a
celebration of online video in all it's
safe for work forms practically this
means its domination by YouTube and more
recently tick-tock before talking in
more detail about Zoey's thesis I wanted
to show you a little bit of how she
approaches industry via this event and
how she conducts some field work thanks
to my friend Hannah Witton I was able to
get in access all areas past for the
VidCon which is oh he also had allowing
us to go to all the panels and events
and behind the scenes we met up at a
packed panel that Hannah was speaking on
about creator burnout when you're
watching something like that
how are you deceptive because I'm
watching it as a creator and kind of
empathizing I am empathizing because my
PhD is about the experiences of creators
and and because I'm an anthropologist
I'm trying to like get into the minds of
the creators as much as possible but at
the same time I'm trying to think about
how it fits into existing literature
right so that correlates with I read in
this study like for example that
something that always sticks out in
general when you're studying creative
industries labor in the creative
industries is this kind of idea that you
do what you love for a living
yeah which has been critiqued a lot in
the literature and it's not a critique
of the people who do that labor at all
because everyone wants to do what they
love for a living but it's a critique of
what that means and this perfectly
highlights that because it's like the
idea that you would work all hours of
the day it's very typical in the
creative industries yeah and the
justification is often all I'm doing
what I love it's like well no no one
should be working all the time and
that's actually a really toxic structure
basically I'm doing an ethnographic
study of youtubers well it started as
youtubers and now I say content creators
because that is the term that people use
and people work across platforms I'm
trying to understand their lived
experiences and their labor within the
online video industry
there's a lot of research on creative
industries like previous more
traditional like TV and stuff but not
much on like social media industries so
it's also kind of a social media
industry study one of the few
journalists in the world who covers
YouTube meaningfully and is also
interested in studying social media is
Chris Stoker Walker who also wrote in
one of the books on Zoey's shelf he also
chaired the panel my friend Hannah was
on and afterwards we took to the
convention floor together to see how
researchers and journalists view YouTube
events a little bit differently when
you're looking around
he comes to accomplish
what does this insane commercialism do
you see the sort of - so you can see
like the bright lights and the shiny
face but then you go actually
why is this here what is the purpose of
air like water
because it says which is that like
change
suddenly greatest walk scooping and so
you can everybody in a room like I have
done reparation where
you get from one state to another
and you're told not to walk around
you're afraid
so even one teens
very green
we found something old people are
actually interested in man it's so
strange to see something that was at my
childhood better in like a case we were
just saying that there's big tick-tock
activation or something
go goodbye I immediately also fall for a
bot horse I think it's interesting
comparing this year to last year last
year I felt quite dead I described it as
like a colonial exhibition for a dying
Empire last year
and it was different I think this year
is the tick tock as and it's so much
capital so much energy and a younger
audience to it would you think Chris is
definitely expecting the whole world
line for doing this really of bowing
money
they are paying for those events and
discussions in the whole thing they are
paying for the beaten 3-ball and also
when you go out into the actual kind of
like everyday environment in the Excel
they are like the ticket offers are the
ones that are actually kind of roaming
about because they're not actually
officially acknowledged and they're also
not so big that they're gonna get
swamped looking a little bit behind the
lens here we've been watching this group
here prepare to do a tic toc for what's
felt like the past five minutes their
camera guy is possibly just stolen the
camera and that you just picked it up
and run in that direction we're
wondering if they're gonna get moved on
by security before they can actually
finish filming exciting developments
their camera guys returning very very
slowly as the guy in orange out of the
way I'm trying to film somebody filming
a tick-tock here
I could record a tick-tock faster than
this I could download the app learn how
to do it a dance and do it faster than
Earth
oh my god they mess it up
I assumed that there was like a dance
true branding
that was it
what we've seen so far is what Zoe is
studying and how she collects her data
but how do you convert observations from
a VidCon and from watching YouTube
videos into a thesis she invited me to
her department at LRC to take a look at
her system how she converts the raw data
into something more meaningful and to
discuss her findings so this is the
software that you've been using to kind
of categorize and make sense of all of
your field notes so what data have you
put into this well there are lots of
other programs you can use but this is
just the one that I use but basically I
categorize it by type of data collection
so Auto ethnography those are my auto
ethnographic field notes about making
videos general field notes I have
interviews I've got a few other names on
here that you may or may not recognize
VidCon UK USA though that's where I keep
my field notes for that and then I have
my online ethnography which I split down
into different types as well so can you
show you like an example of the actual
raw data so you have my interview
transcripts yeah the reason I know Zoey
is because nearly two years ago she
interviewed me as one of her earliest
bits of data collection for the thesis
and the transcripts of the interview
reveals that I was somewhat fresh out of
the PhD myself when she talked to me but
how do you convert like this transcript
how do you convert the raw data yeah
into something that you can write about
so I'm guessing right just scrolling
through
so obviously the interviews all look
like this is very this was a three and a
half hour interview I think so long some
of them were like an hour long those are
just the interviews though which is like
one third probably of my data collection
and then so for example when I'm doing
online ethnography where I'm going
across platforms I'm basically
collecting screenshots of anything I
think is interesting okay
the one that I think is probably most
useful is YouTube videos and comments
okay so you go this is how much you paid
for me from
million dude video and when I import it
I'll basically highlight this title and
then I'll code it this is whether you're
using code in a different sense to what
I would use you want happy so I would
use it in terms of like programming
right no like Python or something yeah
is it almost like a form of metadata
it's like the type of analysis is called
thematic analysis so you could do theme
attic analysis on anything I'll do it on
my field notes on my videos that I
collect on my interview transcripts on
everything and basically I'm just
assigning some words whatever it could
be one word it could be a sentence
whatever to that data that I've imported
okay so it could be talking about that
that might have the coding of like money
for example exactly so like let's see if
I start to type it in you'll see all of
my codes that are existing that I
already have but same anyway
you know creators work on other channels
for money conspicuous consumption versus
coin us about money but I would code
this I'd also code it to the person and
the date right so I have multiple
different kind of intersections of codes
so you're basically crunching down all
the raw data into like a refined form
yeah with ethnographic research its
inductive and it's called grounded
theory and the point is that you
basically collect at the beginning you
don't know exactly what you're looking
for right you know what the culture is
that you're looking for like I knew I
was going to be studying YouTube when I
started I didn't even know I was gonna
be studying the labor of content
creators right so it was so broad it was
like I want to know everything about
this industry I want to talk to
audiences I want to talk to creators I
want to talk to industry people and then
once I started actually getting into it
the thing that I was drawn to and found
most interesting was the labor of
content creators so you write notes and
the notes I wrote at the beginning of my
project this was the first bit of
offline field work I did there so broad
like the things I'm talking about aren't
really about the things that I'm talking
about now because the the basically a
project follows what they call like
hammers lien Atkins and cool a funnel
structure we start really broaden it
gets narrower and narrower as you get
towards the end of the project the
coding does the same thing it's an
iterative process so you're coding
throughout and then you have your nodes
which I'll show you
and you refine the nodes the thematic
analysis over time to to be grouped into
like meta nodes or codes and then those
become the big themes for the project
welcome to day 2 have VidCon I'm up here
in the Creator track we're going to have
a look into some of the sessions but
also there is they meet up other study
tubers which I feel like oh God
getting everybody at height is gonna be
interesting pixel girls subscription box
honestly you two I swear all she watched
is yes called
out right now you know and we would just
do well what how it was a meet-up for
@gp when it was study - yes - what do
you get what's the purpose that's really
standard things like you get to meet so
many viewers you only ever usually meal
I suppose I could meet to meet up but
also networking what you meeting other
creators exactly exactly
kind of the same for me like I don't
think that talks themselves were hugely
you know interesting whatever but like
talking to the people during the talks
and after the talks was like really good
my theory of VidCon is this like a
renaissance trained fair and you get
like all the weavers from all across the
kingdom come in one oh it's really
strange to meet people because you might
never seen them on a screen and then
like to see them 3d I wish it is a
little bit disorienting you know in a
funny old way being here and everybody
filming in fact that you know there's
like content creation happening right
behind me though it's just people
filming a making stuff this does
incredibly at home for me this is the
way that I this is my job you know
and yet at the same time it's so
apparent that my job is only a small
part of online video
you know edge you doing stuff about
science is such a tiny sliver at the
Pine here you see the whole thing you
see just how bizarre a lot of this is
and I think I see in a way I kind of see
my job from an outside perspective when
I come to events like this because you
realize how ridiculous this this whole
filming thing looks
it's weird I feel both at home and also
alienated from myself basically the
general structure of a thesis in my
discipline is intro lit review and
theoretical framework methodology and
then you have like empirical chapter 1 2
3 usually sometimes for theory
theoretical framework and methodology
and data are both chapters 1 2 & 3 here
are actual empirical chapters and you'll
see here I mean it doesn't say it you
can see what they're called but these
are just provisional they're not the
real titles but they're just to remind
me what I'm talking about but basically
the way this is it was 2 and a bit years
into the project that me and in
conjunction with my supervisor finally
figured out like how to structure the
narrative and basically what it is is
that the first empirical chapter is
going to be like the broad macro level
the industry the talent agents the
events like VidCon and stuff like this
like what is the community industry like
the second one's going to be about the
relationship between creators and
audiences so the kind of miso level what
I would call which is will be the one
probably where I talk most about the
actual content that people make and the
ways in which they interact with their
audiences and it will be to do with like
authenticity and intimacy and money and
then the final chapter is the micro
level of basically the subjectivity of
the creator themselves and I have this
kind of quagmire of ideas going around
at the moment because I haven't really
pinned it down but I know that what I'm
trying to say in that chapter is
something to do is what happens when
someone works in an industry that's a
creative industry but it's also a
heavily quantified and Metra fide metric
it's a metric and algorithm driven query
industry and what happens to the self
when the brand your self brand is you
and your life and your interests
depending on the type of channel
especially with like vloggers or
lifestyle creators you know literally
their life is the product so that last
chapter is all about like the subject
basically the the subject look though it
gets produced in this industry and then
conclusions will be something in the
area of like do you know what they are
yet first yeah I mean I'm sure they'll
be different to what I think they're
going to be now but I know that I'm
trying to figure out what's interesting
or unique about this particular industry
that brings together like is an
extension of previous creative
industries but also is a platform based
into industry is an internet culture
based industry and is heavily designed
around metrics and algorithms I'm trying
to say something about like what does it
mean to work in the intersection of
those two you know it's not the kind of
thing where you can have a definite
conclusion at the end it's not a one
sentence summary yeah do it's a big no
this is a lot of stuff around this
subject it's not that you can draw a
conclusion yeah and basically what you
call it with it with anthropology this
is going to be a monograph so it's a
book it's a hundred will be about a
hundred thousand words that tries by the
end I would hope that someone reading it
would feel like they had a really good
understanding of what it means to work
in this industry what the the kind of
cultural factors that take take part
yeah in working in this industry
something that I was curious about in
making this video was how Zoe and I
approached YouTube differently
we are both trained academics and both
use or used YouTube for an academic
purpose she studies it while I used it
to disseminate my research yet while our
backgrounds are very different and our
interactions with the website coming
from very different angles
there are undeniable similarities
spending several days with Zoe both
filming and discussing academia it
became clear that there are definite
parallels between academia and being a
youtuber and this is something that's
already been researched this concept
called the neoliberal worker subject
which is a concept that I use a lot in
relation to
youtubers or content creators but it
also completely applies to academics
which is like basically when like your
work becomes your life and you're
passionate about your work but you're
also working all sorts of hours and your
friends are also your colleagues and
it's just like your life becomes about
the work yeah and that is unfortunately
so it would seem that while I changed
professions from academia to YouTube
perhaps my work didn't change much at
all
Zoe's research is still ongoing and
she's still drawing her conclusions but
after everything she's learned so far
and everything she's seen and
particularly this similarity between
youtubing and being an academic i had to
ask
would she not want to be a youtuber
herself now instead of just researching
it does this make you want to be a
youtuber more or less having taken such
a deep dive on the experience less yeah
definitely less I've enjoyed making
content and I really like having a
channel where I feel like some people
mostly other researchers can hear about
what I'm studying because I think some
people think that's quite cool that I'm
sharing findings in a video format so
that's actually very unusual thorough
researcher there's no way that I'd want
to do it to earn a living it's so hard
only see I honest I really don't think I
could do it it is it's bull breaking
it's the money thing it's like once you
need to make money you have to then
really worry about your your figures
your viewing figures like or so many
things come into play when you have to
actually earn a living through it but
I'm very happy to make videos and put
them on the internet for people to see
you know which is it beauty being in its
purest form in a sense yeah this video
series is supported by brilliant and if
you've just watched an entire video
about a PhD project then I'll bet that
you're both interested in education and
in pushing yourself brilliant has been
an ideal sponsor for this series because
that's exactly what their website and
app are all about learning through
solving problems pushing yourself and
your understanding of a subject forwards
by tackling questions brilliant are
continually adding new content and just
this month they launched a new course on
cryptocurrency all about the maths and
technology behind cryptocurrencies but
if you'd prefer to push your
understanding of algebra gravitational
physics calculus chemistry or
probability then they have courses on
all these and more personally I've been
learning from the course on chemistry as
a way to stay sane in lockdown and just
spending a few minutes a day tackling
problems and working my brain muscles
has done wonders for my mental health if
you'd like to by brilliant as a gift for
a student you know or be selfish and
keep it to yourself then head to
brilliant org slash Simon Clark and the
first 200 viewers to do so will get 20%
off their annual subscription thanks to
brilliant for their continued support of
this series thanks to Zoe for agreeing
to be part of this series though in a
slight role reversal I think she
actually got more data out of it than I
did and of course thank you for watching
it if you enjoyed it then check out the
other episodes in the series on the
screen right now and if you'd like to
see more make sure you hit that
subscribe button thanks again for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one